Tom how's morale oh I feel great I got
like a egg mcmuffin style sandwich in
front of me a glass of orange juice and
I'm going back home I feel pretty good
if you're a warrior's player how's
morale oh I mean it's up to answer for
everybody but I you going back home to
play Game seven not what you not what
you wanted everybody keeps Santa Peter
told me that in january i always ask
them what if i told you that five days
ago not so much five years ago six
months ago I feel good about it it's
what you play on here for us will you
accumulate those 73 wins for two to get
back home and have a chance to win a
game seven to win a championship or in
the case of the Oklahoma City Series to
advance I come from behind 31 had to
those games at home because you had the
best record so I mean they're gonna that
I mean they're dealing with the team is
on a roll right now I don't necessarily
believe in momentum transferring from
game to game so it all starts new in
Game seven but these guys are I'm sure
it's confidence they've been all season
but hey if you're the team but you would
think you are and the team that won the
most regular-season games in the history
of the NBA then you gotta feel pretty
good about being uh being being at home
for Game seven those those you know home
teams rarely lose those anyway and
they're a good basketball team to try to
be a great basketball team will find out
on Sunday how would you rate the refs
overall last night oh man can I get
fined i think i don't think i can get
fined in i can find any Morgana no I
don't think so and now they weren't good
I mean look they struggled some of the
calls on step four terrible Kevin Love
third foul terrible a couple times they
brought went to the whole I thought he
got fouled I thought this coupled last
night and are we sure I can't get fine
i'm pretty sure okay yeah too late now
tom yeah but may acquire players scuffle
coaches couple resk up i thought they
said that data I thought they had a
tough one last night I thought there was
some fouls both ways that I looked at
Wow
dvds I'm sorry you can't make you can't
make that call on the assumption
somebody got fouled you better know
someone got fouled to make that call I
mean Kevin love's third call a third
foul was on block and he didn't even
touch to him on green going to the hole
so yeah that the this coupled last night
but Steph seemed a little more
aggressive on defense now that the you
know the foul on Tristan Thompson was
just stupid like who cares if Tristan
Thompson scores in the first minute of
the game but the other moments where
he's trying to really put pressure on
Kyrie Irving uh I I thought he put
himself in bad situations a couple of
times I thought he'd picked Kyrie clean
the one time he was called for a foul as
well but just steps like Steph is now
forced to play a little bit more defense
here and you're seeing a little bit more
frustration with him then we sold during
the regular season how surprising is
this well I mean I think it mounts I
think when you're up three-to-one you
expect to close it out and you find
yourself on the brink of a Game seven I
think frustration levels are going to
rise a tad bit look we at least have a
saying and I still use it don't put
yourself in a position for the referee
to blow the whistle and when you do it
sometimes you're going to get a bad call
you fly out good for a three guy guy
shooting at three and you fly out wildly
maybe you didn't hit him but you're
gonna give the official an excuse to
call the call the foul so there were a
couple of those last night but I mean
three of them that that that was the
problematic Steve had during the
postgame presser was it wasn't just one
it was he picked him and his sixth foul
was the was a bad call there is maybe
another one out there that I thought was
kind of a week all but well that didn't
they did it lose because of the
officials and I think it's funny I was
talking to somebody and it's a good why
does he care about the officials
nowadays and when I played no one cared
about the officials don't care about who
was behind home plate now you got all
the referee listings and they tell you
who's gonna be repping the games with me
up in the games and then all it does get
people up in arms oh no he's going to be
yo no not not that guy so last night I
tweeted out Latin I some people got it
some didn't I said that's at the red the
NBA's announced the officials for for
game seven it's gonna be ken kaiser red
passion and Phil Luckett who wouldn't
love that old school absolutely broken
cars used to punch people hung up and I
love that who had a worse night steph
curry or his wife uh my goodness I know
she was super frustrated I think we all
know that but being that being that she
could have had a rough night on Twitter
and they could have still won that one
didn't have anything to do with the
other i'm going to say steph probably
had a rougher night not they didn't play
it didn't play well I mean him and clay
were the only reason they're in the game
last night because they're able to shoot
well but I I think when you're a player
and it's 31 and you're at home you're
thinking man this could be sweet when I
wrap this baby up at home gonna be good
to go and then three letters happen l be
J my goodness I was saying to the
audience that appreciate this I know we
bang on LeBron for a variety of reasons
but what he's done I mean he's the MVP
of the finals to me whether they win or
lose he's been unbelievable I mean he
has been he's been he's been awesome the
last two games i think it's 41 points 12
rebounds 9 assists three and a half
steal three blocks very absolutely
incredible I don't know but goes for the
MVP I always would like to give it to
the winning team since that's the goal
the whole exercise to win when they
could be the winning team will be could
be yeah well that wasn't that a no
brainer yes but at that you don't even
okay but who do you give it to Golden
State okay who won Golden State you know
is it somebody's got to win it so you'll
give it to who well I mean obviously a
lot would depend on Game seven uh you
know clays probably had his two best
games in losing efforts uh I don't know
depends on kind of game steps would have
draymond was a very good last night got
suspended for game five it will do they
lost that might bolster his case I don't
know I mean he could be right and I'm
not saying that he's even if they lose
i'm not saying that he's not the best
player in the series and that's that's
clear he's been the best player in the
series since his start in the last two
games of only you know bolstered his
case I don't know it's only seems weird
to give an MVP of a series to a losing
team when the whole exercise is sort of
win the damn thing he's Tom Tolbert the
former NBA player Warriors analyst for
KNBR radio how did the Warriors not win
game 7 what goes wrong LeBron goes wrong
for them again he has a monster game uh
hey look I last night there's not a
whole lot you can do with him I mean
Kyrie is the one you got to make sure
you try to keep down Kyrie can hit some
tough shots but lebron's it and jump
shots it's tough especially with Bogut
out and their centers and play
particularly well last night he can
attack the rim as well but then when he
gets in transition but really for them
they got a limit turnovers that's always
a key because when you get LeBron James
in the open court you could forget about
it I know it sounds simple but they
can't hit shots I mean they missed so
many shots last two games wide open
shots you know he'd love to say well you
know Cleveland's played really good
defense and a half they've been physical
they've got after him and they're
busting their butts out there but that
being said I mean you know Harrison
Barnes has to hit a shot play wasn't
sitting it going to the second half
Shaun Livington scuffled a little bit I
mean they just have to hit some open
shots I mean Charles Barkley says it all
the time there jump shooting team but
maybe the best jump shooting team in the
history of the game over the last couple
games they really haven't been the best
jump shooting team so they're gonna have
to hit some shots get the crowd go to go
crazy and drop a couple threes on them
and then keep LeBron under 50 hey Tom
safe travels back thanks for joining us
thanks I appreciate have a girl man all
right buddy Tom Tolbert warriors analyst
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you